hi this is Matt Welch editor recent
magazine and we just found here at
Denver Civic Center a gaggle of Liberty
what are you hi jinx what I don't even
know what they're doing they're going to
explain it to me introduce yourselves
one by one and tell us a little bit
about what you're doing here at the
convention I'm Wesley Dickinson Justin
Longo Ross Kaminsky just an acre all
right so you guys are what are you doing
what and what does it have to do with a
man in an orange suit well what happened
is we're in Denver we're all from Denver
and the convention coming here we wanted
to we wanted to cover some of the
stories we're going to be in the
trenches that we didn't think we'd get
covered necessarily by the mainstream
media that was worried about the
choreographed all the choreographed
events in the Pepsi Center and invesco
field so a group of you know there's
libertarians there's Republicans there's
conservatives there's capitalists their
center right people that just wanted to
get out and really report on all the
news that we don't think that everyone's
going to pick up and get sanitized
before it makes to the real real media
so we're out here shooting pictures
shooting video some of it's a bit candid
camera where we have a guy that's a he
dresses up in costumes every day and
goes out and infiltrates the crowd first
day he looked like a hippie with no tie
dye and a big Rastafari had on today
he's actually we got him in a Gitmo suit
and he's going around with a petition
that's saying that we need more rights
for these these prisoners of these
political prisoners and having people
signed forgiven them you know they need
to have ESPN one espn2 access to netflix
you know better air conditioning gift
certificates to to radio shack so just
just a bunch of nonsense that you
wouldn't believe the type of responses
you get and like what well just that the
complete lack of understanding of free
markets and capitalism where they truly
believe that Marxism is the way to go
they believe that that the world would
be perfect if it was communist there's
girls and I said well you may you may
may have heard this we may not have
heard this before but there was a guy
that said
from each according to his ability to
each according to his needs now if you
ever heard that guy says yeah yeah you
know that was marks right is he one of
your heroes and these people worship
them and it's it was it's frightening
actually to see all of that so that's
what we're doing out here we're just
going around mingling with people as you
can see we're dressing to blending in
trying to a see don't normally dress
like I just thought this was the Denver
national costume well you know it that
would be bolder you know the other thing
interesting what's going on is you know
a lot of these people are just naive
young kids but a lot of them really are
sort of committed radicals you know one
world type of people against not just
this American government but any
American government and we're finding a
lot of very interesting stuff a lot of
people around who dislike Obama and the
Democrats nearly as much as they dislike
bush in the Republicans it's it's pretty
in because the Democrats are sellouts or
because they're owned by the
corporations just like the Republicans
are and they won't promise to have no
more war primarily where can our recent
TV if you were see all these magical
vote videos and stuff that you're
putting together well if you if you hop
on your internet browser and go to ww
people's press collective dot org you'll
see our logos and wonderful socialist
red fist and we've got people's press
collective around it using the number of
satire a little sarcasm and figure that
well you know the left is used the
symbols of socialism for so long and
socialism is already killed so many
people we're just going to take their
symbols away from them and we're going
to use them that's great thanks very
much for recent TV I Matt Welch
goodnight